every time i get in the car
and i'm thinking is this the one that's
going to beat me to death
all right jackie yes jackie where'd you
grow up where are you from
originally nothing is california raising
watts
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were a kid i
never knew my father
and my mom abandoned me when i was two
years old
when my grandmother found me i had to
learn how to walk again because i was so
male nervous that
i couldn't walk
so as i grew up she had a daughter and
i wasn't treated like her daughter at
that beat her daughter didn't get beat
i ran away several times i always end up
going back
by the time i was 16 16 17
i was raped by my teacher imagine that
and she didn't believe me she didn't
believe me
so she sent me to casually to where
scheduling it's a mental hospital kevin
she thought i had a sex problem
and he said he said basically the same
thing
she said i asked for it
so i figured if everybody felt that way
i don't have to be here why am i here
i never felt loved i never understood
what love was
i'm sorry
so i reached out for a lot of different
ways
do you feel like you were ever loved i
still don't feel like i'm loved
i can't i feel lovely but i don't know
how to love myself
can't nobody do nothing to me that i do
worse to myself
i treat myself worse than anyone anybody
ever could
because i don't think i deserve to be
happy
i put myself in deadly situations on a
day-to-day basis
i don't have people watching my back as
tiny as i am i'm not afraid to walk down
the street and get in cars with
two or three different men i've had guns
pointed to my
head i've been beaten
i just stabbed he almost died
i didn't know he's going to be this hard
i'm sorry and then on top of that i
started getting high and i didn't help
either
sometimes i wonder why am i here
there's no purpose for me here
why did god put me here everybody that
come in contact with me i heard
so what's my point
your childhood is so rough that
you never learn to love yourself
i never felt this so i don't know what
it is
for some reason i think it's supposed to
hurt
do you think that's what maybe attracts
a lot of women to this this lifestyle is
low self-esteem and they don't know how
they they don't think they deserve to be
happy
at least that's what i feel i can't talk
with nobody else
but i feel that i don't deserve to be
happy
because this lifestyle kind of provides
treatment that's
and then when i get high it takes that
thought away for a little while
and i forget about it but then when i
come down i have to get high
some more tricks to get high all over
again to make the thoughts go away
it's like suicidal i'm just too scared
to do it that way so i do it different
ways
because in the back of my mind i really
didn't want to die
[Music]
you started working the street at what
age 17
i'm sure you've had bad experiences yeah
but it was weird though because like
when i started
i was hungry not just walking down what
was that
somewhere on broadway and i was just
walking down the street
and this guy he seemed real nice he said
you need a ride so i got in the car
he says i've never done this he says i
got
25 can we do something
i said yeah and it was quick and easy
the next few times was quick and easy
but then i met that one person that
wanted to beat me
and it took the money back and
but yet i kept doing it and i'm still
doing it i'm 54 years old
it's still working yeah
obviously something has to change i'm
getting close
but i don't know nothing else that's all
you've ever done
all i've never done i love to read
though
i'd love to read i'm very intelligent
i'm an intelligent stupid person you
have children
i have many children three i have a gay
children
how many and nine women and three
deceased
so you lost them i lost three at one
time
they died in a car accident yeah so
together we had 12.
i learned drug addicted one
all of what other world with drugs and
their system what one oh really
yeah another brace none of them you're
still using today
yes correct yeah
can you imagine what your life might
have been like if you had loving parents
and uh
in a good childhood i see other people
like that but i just can't see
me that way i can't picture it
it's a shame
it's a short story but it's mine
i don't know what else to do
i'm sure it gets you depressed yeah
i take depression medication you do yeah
because i get depressed i get suicidal
so they don't want me getting depressed
have you tried suicide yeah that's why i
thought they were i don't take pills
anymore
i don't like pain that way so i'm scared
of blood so
you know i walked out in front of a car
before
[Music]
didn't work so i'm still trying to
figure out why am i here
you know then they say he don't make
mistakes
but i don't i don't believe that because
i think i
am
and the guys who pick you up tell me
about them
oh you got a bunch of weird ones you got
some nice ones you do
but you get more strange ones than you
get
you got some that are nice and they just
want your company
and you have some that want to be
dominant and want you to crawl around on
the floor
then you just got some weird ones like
one when once you once
they want to piss off on you or watch
them sit in a paper bag and smear it on
them
it's weird they do have some weird ones
what's the hardest part of this
lifestyle for you
right now
every time i get in the car
and i'm thinking is this the one that's
going to beat me to death
and a weird part of the body though i
don't know if that's the hard part
enough because i smile and get in the
car
you do it anyway i'll do it that's what
they say insanity is right
doing the same thing expecting different
results
what was the best time of your life
when i had my first baby
yeah when i first looked at him
i thought i was happy that two seconds
when they you know they put the baby
right here and you look down at that
and then i say what the hell am i gonna
do with this
it's crazy i like the way it feels when
pregnant
i like the fact something's going inside
of me
but then they come out oh no dude i want
to win did you raise your kids
no who raised them i raised my first
child for like two weeks
i can't do it mentally i can't
so the system
um family a couple fathers
one is a couple of them i don't even
know what they look like
okay i mean i seen them
when they took them out and you know but
i couldn't tell you what they look like
if they walked up with them in front of
me i couldn't tell you what they look
like
how do you think your years of working
the streets has changed
i still try to be a nice person
i still say just cause i'm industries
the space don't have to be in me
i still try to treat people the way i
want to be treated
but there's a flip side
excuse my life but i could be the nicest
person you want to be
until you draw first black then it's my
turn
i'm very patient and you might not ever
notice me
but i'm gonna get you
i'm sorry i'm sorry
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
whatever you do no matter what it
you're gonna be is dope head be the best
opener you can be
and you're gonna be a hooker be the best
cookie you can be
no half step and nothing
that'll make sense to you does it that's
it
this is all i know so i'm gonna be the
best i can be
put your best foot for it
all right jackie thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
can i go now you're beautiful
i think you're beautiful
you